i noticed in the credits you thanked
steve pegg and flynn
for funding your comic book collection i
think that's a little bit nice who
really funded the collection was it
steve pegg or flynn
uh it would be i mean
probably my mom probably peg funded most
of it
and there it really is i get it um
do you still have your comics from
growing up are you one of these people
that saved everything
uh i do have a bunch of them yeah
because when i came to la
i had to sell some of them during you
know some moments in my 20s but uh
um yeah but i had i had a i still have
quite a few they i i think i don't have
enough and others think i have too many
in an emergency you can only grab one or
two comics
to save entire collection what are you
saving
uh probably some of my early ish
you know it's when i was growing up like
maybe i'm 15 years old
some of the avengers from that era i
loved i had some x-men
from probably before that era that cost
me like
i don't know at the time four bucks
which was a lot but you know some of the
art
you know from that from the the burn art
was so good
um probably those and then um
i think the new some of the new stuff is
so good with uh brian michael bendis you
know all the those writers
but uh yeah i mean i it's sort of i i i
tend to land on
uh marvel stuff mostly but um yeah it
was avengers and x-men and that's that
kind of thing would probably i would
probably
make some choice selections from them i
get it
if you made a superhero movie how much
did you think about putting an after the
credit scene
oh like an easter eggy thing like
yeah um well it's hard to do
with the very first one right because
you're um
because you don't have the you're
spending a lot of time with the world
building of it all
so i had to settle for a uh
some uh you know a quick a quick cut and
then uh some
uh some more jason bateman and melissa
mccarthy uh shenanigans but um
i would love to have you know there's
more stuff that we would love to do if
the movie is received well and
you know people want more uh but then
yeah i would love
you know the world building of it all i
think is one of the most brilliant
things that they
have all done you know it's a what a
good idea uh i love jason bateman in the
movie
i loved his crab claw hands um what
would i mean i know you're
friends with them but what is it like
pitching him on doing this movie and
being like just to let you know i'm
thinking
crab claw hands um
so uh it's funny you should mention that
because he's so busy you know with ozark
and everything
um i pitched him but we so we text all
the time you know because he's sometimes
he's
out of the state and he's flying back
and forth he's just such a busy
guy um and usually we're texting about
baseball
and then in the midst of one of these
baseball texts i'm like hey
do you want to be in our movie what
you'd be a crab question mark what
and so he uh and then but then um
when it's i we were trying to get the
schedule together
um and he just kept uh so i would see
him and he'd be like look
this is my audition i'm like pretty good
man
you're in you're definitely in he's like
can't we make the schedule work i'm like
please yes we should
um so once the schedule was done he was
uh he was all in he's a
he's just such a funny guy he's such a
good friend uh i know i have to go but i
just want to ask real fast how many
takes you
got ruined from the crew laughing
because he's so
deadpan and so funny i couldn't give you
an exact number but i could tell you
that
uh i had to scrub myself out of the
sound
a lot because i was laughing so hard at
uh everything he did he's
god he's funny yeah he's okay
let's not let's not inflate the ego
anyway listen congrats on the movie
i really enjoyed it have a fantastic
time in australia
oh thank you see ya